this is the new anchor nano power bank
it has a pop-up USBC adapter that works
perfectly to fast charge your new iPhone
15 now we're going to see how long it
takes to charge my new iPhone 15 from 5%
to 20% and I'm going to juggle the
entire time hopefully I'm going to try
this is the anchor fast challenge can
you beat the fastest charge for the USBC
[Music]
iPhone I've been juggling for less than
5 minutes and it's already at 14% that's
fast but this is
exhausting 15% come on let's go little
anchor okay we're 8 minutes in and we're
at 18% we're so
close are we 20% what no way oh my
goodness okay we are under 10 minutes
look at this 20% my arms hurt I look
forward to seeing your anchor fast
challenges share them with me please